HARASSING A YOUNG STAFFER.
A LOT TO GET TO.
WE START WITH FRIDAY'S BREAKING
NEWS AND OPENING MONOLOGUE.
GLAD YOU'RE WITH US.
MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP-HATING
NOT -- LET ME REPEAT, DID NOT
FIRE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER.
YOU IDEOLOGUES NEED TO TAKE A
DEEP BREATH OR XANAX OR DRINK
AND BREATHE IN THROUGH THE NOSE
HYSTERIA AND LISTEN CLOSELY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NOT FIRE THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER.
IN FACT, THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
LEGAL TEAM HAVE BEEN MORE THAN
COOPERATIVE.
THEY'VE VOLUNTARILY HANDED OVER
20,000 PAGES AND ROBERT MUELLER
HAS COLLECTED 1.4 MILLION PAGES
OF DOCUMENTS FROM THE CAMPAIGN.
THEN THERE'S THIS, ACCORD TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND OTHER
MEDIA OUTLETS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
DEMANDED ROBERT MUELLER BE
FIRED.
FOX NEWS IS REPORTING THE
PRESIDENT DID NOT ORDER HIM TO
BE REMOVED.
INSTEAD THERE WAS A CONVERSATION
IN JUNE GIVEN MUELLER'S MASSIVE
CONFLICTS OF INTERESTS.
THAT'S IS WHY LAST NIGHT I DID
NOT -- AND WILL NEVER IN THE
FUTURE, TRUST "THE NEW YORK
TIMES."
PAPER OF RECORD.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> FAKES NEWS, FOLKS.
FAKE NEWS.
>> WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE?
>> TYPICAL "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
STORY.
>> Sean: IT DIDN'T MATTER TO THE
LIBERAL MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND
LAST ANYTIME WHEN "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" POSTED THIS STORY TEN
MINUTES BEFORE THIS STORY, THE
MEDIA GOES IN A FRENZY AND
FOAMED AT THE MOUTH.
IT'S FUNNY ON ONE HAND AND SAD
BECAUSE JOURNALISM'S DEAD.
STATES TRIED TO FIRE THE
DOES THAT RISE TO THE LEVEL OF
AN IMPEACHABLE FINANCE?
>> IT'S A QUESTION WHETHER HE'S
IGNORANT OR CORRUPT.
YOU LEAN TOWARDS CORRUPT.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS DONE
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
INVESTIGATION --
>> IT ADDS TO THE MOUNTING
EVIDENCE THERE'S A SERIOUS
OBSTRUCTION CASE HERE.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS MOVIE
ENDS BUT THERE IS A LOT OF
BLOODSHED IN THE GOT FATHER  --
GODFATHER AND IT'S GOING TO BE A
ROUGH YEAR.
>> Sean: IT'S PREDICTABLE FROM
THE NEWS MEDIA.
THEY NEVER WASTE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SMEAR THE PRESIDENT AND DON'T
DESTROY DONALD TRUMP.
YOU SEE IT HOUR IN, HOUR OUT,
DAY BY DAY AND MINUTE BY MINUTE.
THAT'S WHY THE MEDIA HAS BEEN
CAUGHT IN THE WRONG, COUNTLESS
TIMES, MAJOR NEWS STORIES.
FROM LAST YEAR, FAKE NEWS, CNN,
THE OLD NETWORK, THEY FALSELY
REPORTED DONALD TRUMP JR.
RECEIVED AN E-MAIL ON WIKILEAKS
AND FAKE NEWS, CNN GOT THE DATE
OF THE E-MAIL WRONG.
IT CAME ONE DAY AFTER WIKILEAKS
MADE THE DNC DOCUMENTS PUBLIC.
REMEMBER ABC'S BRIAN ROSS WRONG
WHEN HE REPORTED GENERAL MICHAEL
FLYNN WAS GOING TO TESTIFY
PRESIDENT TRUMP ORDER HIM DURING
THE CAMPAIGN TO CONTACT RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS.
THAT FAKE NEWS TANKED THE STOCK
MARKET AND ROSS HAD TO ISSUE A
CORRECTION SAYING IT HAPPENED
DURING A TRANSITION.
I CAN THINK OF OTHER PEOPLE THAT
SHOULD BE BANNED AS WELL.
WE HAVE A DISHONEST WASHINGTON
POST REPORTER DAVID WEIGL
SHOWING A TINY CROWD AND THE
CAPTION READS "PACKED TO THE
RAFTERS."
HERE'S THE PROBLEM, THE PROBLEM
IS DECEPTIVE BECAUSE IT WAS
TAKEN BEFORE MOST PEOPLE HAD
GOTTEN IN THERE AND HE LATER
APOLOGIED AND DELETED THE TWEET.
THAT'S YOUR MEDIA AT ITS FINEST
AT WORK AND THOSE ARE ONLY A FEW
OF THE MANY EXAMPLES OF EPIC
FAKE NEWS SCREW-UPS AND
ANYTIM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED
ABOUT MUELLER AND THERE'S
HYSTERIA, THE SKY IS FALLING AND
BREATHLESS COVERAGE.
NOT SURPRISING FOR OVER A YEAR
THEY'VE BEEN PUSHING CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
THERE'S BEEN NO EVIDENCE AND THE
MEDIA'S BEEN OWE BELIEVIUS TO
THE BIGGEST
OBLIVIOUS STORY OF THEIR LIFE
TIME AND THEY'VE MISSED THE
BOAT.
THIS IS GOING TO MAKE WATERGATE
LOOK LIKE AN AFTERTHOUGHT AND
ONLY A FRACTION OF THE
INFORMATION HAS COME OUT.
WE'VE BEEN REPORTING NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT AFTER MASSIVE, SEVERE
CONSTITUTIONAL ABUSES COMMIT
CLINTON E-MAIL INVESTIGATION WAS
A SHAM.
IT WAS RIGGED.
THE FIX WAS IN.
AND TONIGHT WE HAVE NEW TEXT
MESSAGES FROM CORRUPT
TRUMP-BASHING FBI LOVERS PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE AND WAS
LEAKING INFORMATION TO THE
MEDIA.
LOOK AT THE DATE, OCTOBER 28,
2016, AFTER NEWS BROKE THE NEWS
AND PAGE FINISHES SAYING MIKE'S
PHONE IS ON FIRE.
STRZOK RESPONDS IT'S ON THE NEWS
THEN ADDS, YOU MAY WANT TO TELL
DEVLIN TO TURN ON CNN AND STRZOK
SAYS SORRY AND PAGE RELIES, HE
KNOWS.
HE JUST GOT HANDED A NOTE AND
STRZOK SAYS, AH, HE'S ASKING
MINUTES AFTER THE TEXTS BARRETT
WRITES E-MAILS WERE COPIES OF
CLINTON E-MAILS THE FBI HAS
ALREADY LOOKED AT.
WE REACHED OUT TO THE REPORTER
AND HE TOLD US, NO COMMENT.
SHOCKING.
SO WE HAVE WHAT LOOKS LIKE LEAKS
FROM PAGE AND STRZOK AND THERE'S
SO MANY MORE.
50,000 TOTAL.
IT'S ONLY THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG.
GO BACK TO FEBRUARY 2016, PAGE
MESSAGES HER BOYFRIEND, STRZOK,
ONE MORE THING, SHE MAY BE OUR
NEXT PRESIDENT THE LAST THING
YOU NEED IS US GOING IN LOADED
FOR BEAR.
DO YOU THINK SHE'LL CARE IT'S
FOREDOJ THAN FBI?
AND SO THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT
INVESTIGATING CLINTON BECAUSE
SHE MAY END UP MAD AT THEM AND
REVENGE AND THEY'RE TRYING TO
HELP HER.
THEN MONTHS LATER IN MAY,
REMEMBER, JAMES COMEY AND STRZOK
AND OTHER KEY FBI OFFICIALS
STARTED RIGHTING CLINTON'S
EXONERATION STATEMENTS MONTHS
BEFORE INTERVIEWING HER AND 17
OTHER KEY WITNESSES.
WHEN DO YOU WRITE AN EXONERATION
BEFORE AN INVESTIGATION?
THIS IS WHERE THEY CHANGED THE
LANGUAGE FROM THE LEGAL
STANDARD, GROSS NEGLIGENCE IS A
CRIME.
THEY TAKE THAT OUT AND PUT IN
A BIG DISTINCTION.
THEY GIVE CLINTON THE GET OUT OF
JAIL FREE CARD AND ALTER
LANGUAGE ABOUT FOREIGN ACTORS
LIKELY HACKING CLINTON'S SERVER
PUTTING PEOPLE'S LIVES AT RISK
AND REMOVED THE REFERENCE TO
E-MAILING PRESIDENT OBAMA WHICH
IN OTHER WORDS, THE FIX ON THE
E-MAIL SERVER SCANDAL WAS IN.
REMEMBER, ANY OF THESE ISSUES
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH THE
E-MAIL SERVER SCANDALS
DESTROYING INFORMATION AND
DESTROYING SPECIAL ACCESS
PROGRAM INFORMATION.
CRIMES, BASHING DEVICES WITH
HAMMERS, OBSTRUCTION.
HAVE YOU STRZOK AND PAGE PUTTING
THE FIX IN WITH COMEY AND McCABE
AND LORETTA LYNCH ALL KNEW AND
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT THE NEED
OF A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
ON MARCH 18, STRZOK WRITES,
THOUGHT OF THE PERFECT PERSON
FITZGERALD OF THE VALERIE PLAME
AFFAIR.
AND YOU HAVE TO GIVE ME CREDIT
IF WE GO WITH HIM AND DELAY
BRIEFING HIM UNTIL I CAN GET
BACK AND DO IT.
IN OTHER WORDS, WITH HIS OWN
PREJUDICE AND OWN POINT OF VIEW
AND OWN SPIN.
LATE NEXT WEEK OR LATER, HE
SAYS.
STRZOK SAYS, I CAN WORK WITH HIM
AGAIN AND DAMN, WE'D GET BLANK
DONE.
PAGE FOLLOWS UP WITH, I KNOW,
LIKE I SAID WE DISCUSSED BOSS
AND HIM YESTERDAY.
ON MAY 13, 2016, PAGE FOLLOWS UP
ON THE IDEA, SHE SAYS TO STRZOK,
HEY, FORGOT TO ASK IF YOU
MENTIONED THE WHOLE SPECIAL
COUNSEL THING TO ANDY.
WE ASSUME THAT'S FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW McCABE.
WHAT STRZOK AND PAGE IS
STUNNING.
STRZOK HAD A MASSIVE ROLE IN THE
ENTIRE CLINTON E-MAIL PROBE.
HE OVERSAW THE INTERVIEW WITH
HILLARY CLINTON AND HER TOP
AIDES LONG AFTER THE WROTE THE
AND THEY'RE BOTH SAYING SPECIAL
RELEASED MESSAGES ON MAY 19.
STRZOK APPEARS TO BE TALKING
ABOUT GETTING AN OFFER TO JOIN
MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS IT KEY.
STRZOK SAYS, MY ANSWER'S NO, I
DON'T WANT TO JOIN THAT
INVESTIGATION.
THEN THE LEAD DIVISION AND THEN
I THINK, WAIT A MINUTE, IT MAY
BE A CASE THAT WILL BE IN THE
MY EXTRA TIME IN THE FIELD AND
ALL THE FIELD CASES, WOULD YOU
TRADE IT?
A MILLION PEOPLE ADD AND STAFF
JOBS -- THIS IS A CHANCE TO DO.
IT MAY BE THE MOST IMPORTANT
CASE OF OUR LIVES.
AROUND 30 MINUTES LATER STRZOK
IMPEACHMENT.
THERE'S NO THERE, THERE.
TO BE PART OF HISTORY BUT
AND TWO DAYS AFTER MUELLER WAS
NAMED SPECIAL COUNSEL STRZOK
SAYS IF I THOUGHT IT WAS LIKELY
I'D BE THERE.
I HESITATE BECAUSE MY GUT SENSE
AND CONCERN THERE'S NO BIG
OFFICIAL SIGNED THE PAPER TO
AND HER INVOLVEMENT IN THE
CLINTON E-MAIL SERVER COVER-UP.
IT'S JUNE 2016, BILL CLINTON
MEETS LORETTA LYNCH ON THE
TARMAC AND SAID THEY JUST TALKED
ABOUT GRANDCHILDREN AND SHE SAID
SHE'D ACCEPT WHATEVER THE FBI
CONCLUDE.
ALL IS THIS BEFORE HILLARY
AFTER LYNCH'S STATEMENT, SHE'S
WITH WHAT THEY DECIDE AFTER
MEETING BILL CLINTON ON THE
TARMAC AND STRZOK WRITES TIMING
LOOKS LIKE HELL TALKING ABOUT
LYNCH AND CLINTON ON THE TARMAC.
PAGE ADDS, YEAH, AWFUL TIMING.
SINCE SHE KNOWS WHO CHARGES WILL
BE BROUGHT.
NO DECISION WAS MADE AND FOUR
DAYS LATER HILARY'S INTERVIEW
HILARY SHOULD BE INDICT AND HAVE
STRZOK AND LYNCH AND McCABE AND
COMEY KNOWING CLINTON WILL NEVER
THE CORRUPTION HERE -- IF YOU'RE
A "NEW YORK TIMES" WRITER IS
UNPRECEDENTED.
YOU SHOULD BE COVERING A REAL
WHAT IT ALL MEANS.
YOU HAVE HILLARY CLINTON, WE NOW
KNOW FIXED THE PRIMARY AGAINST
BERNIE SANDERS OR I'LL USE DONNA
BRAZILE'S WORD, PUT THE FIX IN,
THAT ALLOWED CLINTON STAY IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL RACE AND THEY WANT
HER TO BEAT DONALD TRUMP SO THEY
OVERLOOK THE CRIMES WITH THE
INCONTROVERTIBLE EVIDENCE AND
THEY TRY TO INFLUENCE THE
ELECTION WITH A BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIER FULL
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION TOOK
THE DOSSIER AND WEAPONIZED THE
TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE AND INVEST
AND TARGETED MEMBERS OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND LATER THE
INCOMING PRESIDENT IF THIS ISN'T
EXTENT OF THE LAW WE HAVE
SHREDDED OUR CONSTITUTION.
HAVE YOU POWERFUL OFFICIALS IN
THE FBI AND DOJ, CLEARLY TRYING
TO CIRCUMVENT WHAT IS THE
WHISTLE YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THEY DID NOT WANT DONALD TRUMP
AGAIN.
THE ONLY WAY TO DO THAT IS TO
MAKE SURE WE GET EVERY FACT AND
BIT OF TRUTH AND EXPOSE IT TO
THE PERSON S INVOLVED NEED TO BE
EXPOSED.
THAT'S WHAT CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
DO, RELESS
RELEASE THE MEMO AND WHAT WE
KNOW IS WE'RE TOLD IT WILL SHOW
SEVERE FISA ABUSES AGAINST THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT AND HIS TEAM.
AND FOX NEWS IS LEARNING THAT
MEMO IS GOING TO BE RELEASED
LIKELY IN A MATTER OF DAYS.
DEMAND, RELEASE THE MEMO.
THE NUMBER WILL GET THROUGH,
202-  224-3121.
PUT PRESSURE ON THEM, TELL